les traces de la tragédie ont disparu
des murs mais les mémoires sont encore
marquées au fer rouge
mais les tâches laissées par cette
attentat sont indélébile c'est ici dans
ce lieu sacré pour la communauté
musulmane qu'un tireur a fait éruption
le 29 janvier 2017 six hommes sont
tombés sous ces balles 19 autres ont été
blessés pour la première fois les
commémorations de la tragédie ont lieu
là où ils ont laissé leur vie l'exercice
de commémoration d'aujourd'hui est à
l'image d'une alarme et d'un gyrophare
qui clignote pour nous rappeler les
principes fondamentaux qui gouvernent
une société prospère le nécessaire vivre
ensemble c'est au nom de ce vivre
ensemble que le centre culturel
islamique tenait à ouvrir ses portes une
occasion aussi pour passer un message à
l'ensemble de la classe politique au
niveau provincial nous attendons
toujours des actions concrètes c'est à
dire que notre premier ministre aurait
voulu être présent ce soir François
Legault briait d'ailleurs par son
absence c'est la vie ce premier ministre
qui a parlé en son nom sachez bien que
tout notre gouvernement est avec vous
mais l'absence du Premier ministre n'est
pas passé inaperçu on a juste un petit
quelque chose à vous demander c'est de
parler à Monsieur François le groupe
pour lui dire vous aurez dû venir
le fondateur du Centre culturel
islamique croit que la loi 21 sur la
laïcité de l'État nuit ou vivre ensemble
dans la province la violence et la haine
n'ont pas leur place dans notre pays le
Premier ministre Justin Trudeau lui a
nommé cette semaine une représentante
spéciale de la lutte contre
l'islamophobie elle va agir en tant que
conseillère et experte afin d'aider le
gouvernement fédéral dans la lutte
contre l'islamophobie le racisme
systémique la discrimination raciale et
l'intolérance religieuse même si à
chaque année qui passe la communauté
guérit un peu plus de ses blessures les
familles des victimes souhaitent que la
tragédie soit quand même soulignée à
tous les ans c'est pour eux un devoir de
mémoire ici Camille Carpentier
Radio-Canada Québec